Apple has just announced that due to  poor sales they'll be making fewer of  their Apple home pods yeah yeah yeah  there it is the home pod is the virtual  assistant speaker that Apple released to  compete with Amazon's Alexa apparently  Apple users have found that Siri on the  home pod is much worse than Alexa when  it comes to answering even basic  questions that is so weird because I  have one of the Apple home pods and I  think it's great really I think it's  great yeah you just need to know how to  use it right  take a look hey Siri I'm listening  what's the capital of Guatemala one  moment  Alexa Guatemala City is the capital of  Guatemala Andi Guatemala City Thank You  Siri  hopefully I'm the one who I said Thank  You Siri  you gotta know how it's here  you